[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de medio
ambiente en france24 yo soy maría clara
calle las protestas para pedir más
acciones contra el cambio climático
tienen un eslogan en común justicia
climática desde brasil y pakistán hasta
londres y parís se escucha la misma
frase pero qué significa esto en pocas
palabras es reconocer que los que menos
han contribuido con la contaminación son
en gran medida los más golpeados por el
calentamiento global por ejemplo si la
tierra se calienta dos grados celsius
adicionales más de la mitad de la
población de áfrica estará en riesgo de
desnutrición según la onu a pesar de que
todo el continente es responsable de tan
sólo el 3 por ciento de las emisiones
por eso naciones unidas advierten que
aunque todos los rincones de la tierra
se afectan las consecuencias no son por
igual
los impactos del cambio climático no se
asumirán de manera equitativa o justa
entre ricos y pobres mujeres y hombres y
generaciones mayores y más jóvenes
naciones unidas- también estima que los
efectos del calentamiento global se
sufrirán de manera desproporcionada en
áfrica y en asia y uno de los lugares
donde más duro se están sintiendo estas
consecuencias es en madagascar
las escenas en esta isla de africana son
de no creer los malgaches del sur del
país enfrentan la que podría ser la
primera hambruna de todo el mundo a
causa del cambio climático
allí las lluvias son cada vez más
erráticas y los habitantes están
enfrentando la peor sequía de los
últimos 40 años el programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu ha advertido que 1,3
millones de habitantes corren el riesgo
de padecer hambre al estar catalogados
entre los niveles 3 4 y 5 del ipc esta
es una clasificación de seguridad
alimentaria con una escala del 1 al 5
según eso en madagascar casi un millón
de personas están en el nivel 2 es decir
al límite de no garantizar sus alimentos
730.000 están en una crisis aguda y casi
400.000 en emergencia
ocupan cerca de 14.000 personas podrían
padecer hambruna por el cambio climático
especialmente en el distrito de abu
bomba android nuestra periodista marinas
ardilla nos cuenta la historia que
enfrentan miles de habitantes de
madagascar al exponerse a la
desnutrición y al hambre por la
emergencia climática
es la hambruna de la crisis climática en
el sur de madagascar dos de cada cinco
personas necesitan ayuda alimentaria de
emergencia debido a las sequías que por
cuatro años consecutivos ante bastado
los cultivos el principal medio de
subsistencia de los locales las eran las
que la del agua estábamos realmente
indefensos y como esqueletos ya ni
siquiera podíamos caminar
podríamos habernos derrumbado con solo
tropezar con una ramita mis hijos lloran
y lloran tanto con todo su corazón con
todas sus fuerzas este ya se ha
desmayado de tanto llorar hecho la
cultura el calentamiento global cambio
los patrones climáticos de la región sin
lluvia los campos están desnudos y
muchos pasan días sin comer
así que la situación es crítica y la
previsión en cuanto a precipitaciones no
es buena así que la hambruna que
enfrentan un millón 300 mil personas
persiste y como dije en cuanto a
precipitaciones estamos a 450 milímetros
de agua esperada lo que equivale a sólo
un mes de lluvia en un año el mundo
según los expertos las temperaturas en
el sur de áfrica están aumentando el
doble respecto a la tasa mundial
provocando una crisis de emigrantes a
causa del cambio climático personas que
no huyen de los conflictos sino de las
hambrunas provocadas por la emergencia
climática según unicef se espera que
medio millón de niños sufran
desnutrición aguda madagascar
como raíces silvestres pero no podemos
cocinarlas las ponemos en la olla las
tapamos con agua pero quedan crudas las
raíces siempre están duras las comemos
pero no nos llenan
me duele el estómago tengo diarrea
cuando voy al baño me cese son amarillas
y a veces hay sangre me gustaría una
manta ropa y sandalias pero sobre todo
me gustaría comer
estas personas no han contribuido al
cambio climático pero probablemente
están pagando el precio más alto los
países del sur global llevan años
exigiendo mayores responsabilidades a
las naciones ricas que desde la cumbre
climática de 2009 en copenhague
acordaron destinar 100 mil millones al
año en ayudas para que los países
empobrecidos enfrenten el cambio
climático una promesa hasta ahora
incumplida
y así como el calentamiento global
provoca sequías más fuertes en otros
lugares cambian los ciclos de lluvia y
genera más inundaciones uno de los
mayores riesgos es que entre más se
calienta la tierra más se derriten los
glaciares y los polos esto está
provocando que el nivel del mar aumente
de hecho este nivel se ha duplicado
desde el 2006 el ipc se estima que si la
tierra se calienta 15 grados celsius
adicionales los niveles subirán de 30 a
90 centímetros pero si la tierra se
calienta más es probable que el mar suba
más de 1 metro para algunos países esto
es cuestión de vida o muerte y es que el
10 por ciento de la población del mundo
vive en lugares que están a menos de 10
metros sobre el nivel del mar y los más
afectados por esto y por la erosión
costera son los estados insulares como
maldivas kiribati cuba o jamaica desde
allí piden acciones más rápidas y
contundentes
en tuvalú vivimos la realidad del cambio
climático el aumento del nivel del mar
como ustedes ven hoy no podemos esperar
a los discursos cuando el mar está
subiendo a nuestro alrededor todo el
tiempo la acción climática tiene que
estar en primer plano tenemos que tomar
medidas alternativas audaces hoy para
asegurar el mañana estos ejemplos de
tuvalú en la polinesia o de madagascar
en áfrica muestran que el cambio
climático afecta de manera
desproporcionada y los países que menos
han contaminado suelen ser los más
afectados por eso el llamado a la
justicia climática hasta aquí nuestra
emisión recuerden ver más en nuestro
canal de youtube y también en france 24
punto com nos vemos
[Música]